mes chers collègues nous entendons ce
matin monsieur Boris Ravignon candidat
proposé par le Président de la
République pour
occuper les fonctions de président du
conseil d'administration de l'ADEME en
application d'article 13 de la
Constitution nous vous trouverez les
éléments biographiques sur notre
application dimether comme vous le savez
cette nomination ne peut intervenir
qu'après l'audition de la personne
pressentie devant les commissions
compétentes à la fois de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat celle de
l'Assemblée nationale aura lieu à 11h30
audition qui doivent être suivies d'un
vote je rappelle que cette nomination ne
pourra intervenir si l'addition des
votes négatifs de chaque commission
représentait au moins les 3/5 des
suffrages exprimés dans les deux
commissions
cette audition est publique elle est
ouverte à la presse et retransmise sur
le site du Sénat
à l'issue nous procéderons au vote à
bulletin secret
je vous rappelle mes chers collègues qui
ne peut y avoir de délégation de vote et
que le dépouillement doit être effectué
simultanément à l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat
je vais sans attendre passer la parole à
notre rapporteur Martin décidera qui va
conduire cette audition vous pourrez
ensuite nous présenter votre candidature
et nous faire part de vos motivations
avant de répondre au première question
du rapporteur puis mes collègues
sénateurs vous interrogeront à leur tour
pour une séquence de questions réponses
je vous remercie je donne la parole à
madame le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur Ravignon nous sommes
donc réunis aujourd'hui pour examiner
votre candidature à la présidence du
conseil d'administration de l'Agence de
l'environnement et de la maîtrise de
l'énergie nous allons tous ensemble
examiner ce matin les forces et
faiblesses de votre candidature à la
tête d'un opérateur désormais
incontournable dans la conduite des
politiques publiques suivies par notre
commission j'aimerais tout d'abord faire
un petit détour par l'histoire de
l'ADEME qu'il me semble pertinent de
rappeler ici pour mieux apprécier
l'importance de votre candidature à
l'origine en 1982 l'Agence française
pour la maîtrise de l'énergie à l'époque
l'AFME est créée par François Mitterrand
pour réfléchir aux questions d'économie
d'énergie et au développement des
énergies nouvelles l'AFME est alors
perçue comme un contre-pouvoir à EDF
dans un contexte de montée en puissance
du secteur électrique nucléaire en
France
une première étape dans l'inexorable
croissance de l'opérateur dont vous
briguez la présidence et franchit 10 ans
plus tard en 1992 avec la création de
l'Agence de l'environnement et de la
maîtrise de l'énergie l'actuelle ADEME
qui résulte de la fusion de plusieurs
agences préexistantes l'Agence française
pour la maîtrise de l'énergie donc
l'Agence pour la qualité de l'air et
l'Agence nationale pour la récupération
et l'élimination des déchets cette
fusion illustre la dynamique qui sera
dès lors celle de l'ADEME une extension
de son champ de compétence au-delà de
son périmètre initial contenait à
l'énergie
en 2022 l'agence poursuit ainsi des
actions aussi diverses que la mise en
oeuvre des objectifs nationaux en
matière de chaleur renouvelable
d'économie circulaire de mobilité
durable d'amélioration de la qualité de
l'air la reconversion des friches
polluées l'accompagnement des
entreprises et des territoires ou encore
l'adaptation au changement climatique
l'ADEME ce sont aujourd'hui quelques
programmes phares que nous connaissons
bien le fond chaleur pour le
développement de la chaleur renouvelable
dotée en 2023 de 520 millions d'euros
pour le fond chaleur se font connaît une
croissance continue notamment grâce aux
amendements portés par notre chambre et
en particulier par nos deux rapporteurs
budgétaires messieurs Calvet et Monsieur
Martin le fond économie circulaire doté
en 2023 de 210 millions d'euros le font
de décarbonation de l'industrie créée à
la faveur du plan de relance doté de 1
milliard 7 d'euros à la lecture de cette
histoire de la dame on comprend que
l'agence est passée institutionnellement
de la marche au cœur du réacteur si vous
permettez le jeu de mots pour devenir un
acteur incontournable mais autonome
à la lecture de l'histoire de l'ADEME et
de son institutionnalisation progressive
on comprend également que les
problématiques environnementales
qu'elles portent notamment les économies
d'énergie et le développement des
énergies renouvelables ont fini par
irriguer pleinement le débat public
cette croissance continue de l'ADEME
c'est récemment traduite par une très
forte augmentation des moyens
budgétaires mis à sa disposition alors
que son budget fluctué lors de la
précédente décennie entre 500 millions
d'euros et un milliard d'euros il
atteindra en 2023 un niveau record de
4/2 milliards d'euros
je constate toutefois que les moyens
humains n'ont pas suivi dans les mêmes
proportions les effectifs vont certes
augmenté en 2023 avec la création de 90
postes supplémentaires mais il faut
prendre un peu de recul en 2022 les
moyens humains de l'ADEME étaient en
réalité inférieure à ce que l'agence a
connu sur une bonne partie de la
décennie précédente
on sait par ailleurs que le
fonctionnement de l'ADEME se caractérise
par un recours significatif à de
l'intérim ou des contrats à durée
déterminée
cette situation est-elle durable alors
même que les politiques menées par
l'ADEME demandent un suivi au long cours
vous nous éclairez là-dessus monsieur
Ravignon on peut évidemment douter nous
vous attendons donc au tournant
concernant le schéma d'emploi de
d'emploi de l'ADEME espérons que vous
pourrez nous partager ce matin des
éléments rassurants à ce sujet
la croissance passée présente de l'ADEME
nous invite naturellement à vous
interroger aussi sur la trajectoire
d'évolution future de l'opérateur que
vous vous apprêtez à diriger en
particulier
envisagez-vous de positionner la dame
sur de nouveaux périmètres
d'intervention comment comptez-vous
articuler vos compétences avec celles
d'autres opérateurs de l'État qui
interviennent dans des champs proches du
vôtre je pense évidemment au serema
concernant l'adaptation changement
climatique
l'efficacité de l'action publique
implique d'éviter les redondances voir
les logiques de concurrence entre
opérateurs publics qui doivent tous
pousser dans la même direction
il me faut également aborder les
questions relatives à la gouvernance de
la thème profondément impactée par la
récente adoption de la loi 3DS cette loi
attribue en effet au préfet de région la
fonction de délégué territorial de la
dame le préfet de région représentera
localement l'établissement éditera à
l'attention du représentant territorial
de l'établissement des directives
d'action territoriales et participera à
l'évaluation du responsable territorial
de l'établissement si on peut comprendre
la volonté d'un contrôle de l'État sur
un établissement dont l'importance
froide année en année cette évolution ne
doit pas se traduire par une main mise
de Paris sur l'action territoriale de la
dame
nous le savons c'est un motif
d'inquiétude pour votre prédécesseur
monsieur Ravignon pouvez-vous nous
donner des garanties quant à l'autonomie
de l'établissement vis-à-vis de l'État
c'est un point qui sera très important
dans la prestation que nous porterons à
votre candidature
parallèlement la 3DS la loi 3DS
excusez-moi opère un mouvement
décentralisateur auquel nous ne pouvons
que souscrire en effet le législateur a
souhaité mieux associer les
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale à fiscalité propre à la
gouvernance de l'ADEME il a également
prévu la délégation d'une partie des
fonds chaleurs et économie circulaire
gérés par l'ADEME aux régions
volontaires ayant conclu avec l'agence
une convention de transition énergétique
régionale souhaitez-vous renforcer plus
encore les relations et collaborations
entre l'ADEME et les collectivités
territoriales en particulier avec le duo
région intercommunalité
j'aimerais enfin vous poser une question
plus spécifique sur l'application de la
loi relative à la lutte contre le
gaspillage et à l'économie circulaire à
laquelle nous avons largement contribué
nous avons souhaité renforcer les moyens
de l'ADEME pour contrôler les échos
organiques pour cela nous avons créé une
redevance directement prélevée sur les
filières pour financer des ETP dédiés
par ailleurs nous avons élaboré un
régime de sanctions pour pénaliser les
éco-organismes en cas de non respect de
leur obligation et de non atteintes des
objectifs qui leur sont à signer pour
faire avancer notre politique d'économie
circulaire il nous faut maintenant
assurer la crédibilité de cet édifice de
contrôle et de sanction
nous attendons donc de vous que vous
fassiez preuve d'autonomie et le cas
échéant de fermeté vis-à-vis des
filières de responsabilité élargie du
producteur sans cela la loi ajecte sera
un échec
votre responsabilité est très grande et
nous espérons que vous pourrez nous
rassurer quand à votre volonté d'agir
résolument en la matière je vous
remercie pour votre écoute et vous
laisse nous apporter des éléments de
réponse à ces premiers questionnaires
merci Madame
c'est de la parole
voilà merci monsieur le Président merci
madame le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs d'abord permettez-moi de dire
le l'honneur qui est le mien ce matin
d'être auditionné par par votre
commission dans le cadre de ce processus
de nomination à la présidence du conseil
d'administration de l'ADM
des marches qui je crois et me
permettrait monsieur le Président de
commencer par avoir un propos
Natura présenté un peu justement ma
candidature avant de revenir très
précisément sur les questions vous
pouvez poser madame leur rapporteur donc
je voulais d'abord vous dire que cette
démarche est ma présence aujourd'hui ce
matin devant vous ne devez vraiment rien
au hasard
que les questions d'environnement de ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la transition
écologique c'est pas toujours appelé
comme ça notamment au moment du Grenelle
de l'environnement on avait d'autres
termes qui mais ce que nous regroupons
aujourd'hui dans ce large mouvement que
notre société et notre pays est le monde
elle doit engager en termes de
transition écologique et bien ce sont
des sujets qui me motivent me
passionnent et dans lesquels je me suis
impliqué de depuis très longtemps je
faisais mention du Grenelle de
l'environnement parce que c'est
mon engagement politique national a
commencé à ce moment-là au moment où
effectivement conseillé de Nicolas
Sarkozy à la présidence de la République
de 2007 à 2012 j'ai la foi au départ en
aux côtés de Chantal Jouanno sur le
lancement du du cronal de
l'environnement et avec bien sûr les
ministres de l'époque notamment
Jean-Louis Borloo et puis je l'ai mis en
oeuvre aussi à la demande effectivement
du président de la République
pendant les cinq ans qui ont suivi et
donc les les deux grandes lois qui qui
sont nées à ce moment-là et bien ont été
des sujets de de travail presque
quotidien et certains des éléments que
vous mentionniez à l'instant madame le
rapporteur sur le comme le font chaleur
qui sont nés à ce moment-là qui je crois
et toutes les évaluations qui ont été
faites sur le sujet le démon plutôt un
beau succès bien c'est je crois la
petite fierté d'y avoir pu y contribuer
à leur naissance donc ce sujet c'est
sujet je les ai toujours trouvé
absolument essentiel fondamentaux et
quand en 2014 j'ai eu la chance que mes
concitoyens carolo massériens donc
Charleville-Mézières donc je suis
aujourd'hui le maire et bien me fasse
confiance aux élections municipales
permis aussi de de d'assurer la
présidence de l'agglomération
Charleville-Mézières Sedan alors elle
est devenue depuis Ardennes métropole on
cherche tous à être un peu des
métropoles même si on ne fait que 130
000 habitants
et puis qu'on est un territoire très
largement rural mais donc sur ce
territoire et bien j'ai poursuivi moi
c'est très de manière très très active
cette engagement avec un travail sur les
mobilités justement sur les
développements des mobilités actives
mobilité douce ponctuée par un
référendum local que nous avons remporté
l'année dernière sur ce développement du
du vélo dans la Ville de
Charleville-Mézières et qui était je
crois salué par la Fédération des
usagers de la bicyclette la fume qui qui
a constaté Charleville-Mézières était la
ville moyenne qui avait le plus
progressé en termes d'équipement
cyclables au cours des dernières années
ça c'est le domaine des mobilités mais
je ne vais pas ici faire une liste
exhaustive des actions qui ont été
conduites néanmoins nous avons aussi été
je crois précurseur dans le
développement de la mobilité électrique
avec aujourd'hui un équipement en borne
de recharge qui est l'un des meilleurs
de France on a 150 bornes de recharge
sur l'ensemble du territoire de
l'agglomération et ça produit des effets
puisque aujourd'hui le département est
en train de fuir de s'équiper avec un
peu la même densité et donc je les
Ardennes départements effectivement très
largement rural et bien je crois en
partie déjà prise ce virage important de
la mobilité électrique et puis je
pourrais mentionner parce que c'est
aussi dans les dans les politiques de
l'ADEME et je vais y revenir la question
des déchets puisque nous sommes à priori
la première et pour l'instant la seule
agglomération du Grand Est à nous être
engagés dans une tonne incitative pour
aller chercher encore davantage de
réduction des ordures ménagères donc
c'est un vous le voyez c'est ces
questions de transition écologique bien
je après avoir au niveau y avoir
travaillé au niveau national de manière
pour le coup plutôt intellectuel je n'ai
eu de cesse de m'y appliquer et de les
mettre en pratique dans la dans la vie
des lieux locales qui est la mienne
alors ça pas simplement pour le pour
ressemble tout à fait crucial alors on
arrive à un moment qui me semble être
tout à fait particulier ou je crois
qu'il y a vous le disiez vous-même aussi
même le rapporteur
consensus sur le fait qu'il nous faut
avancer et qu'il nous faut désormais si
vous permettez l'expressions passer la
sur multipliée massifiées cette
transition écologique à la fois pour nos
concitoyens les particuliers mais aussi
pour les collectivités ici au Sénat à
quel point vous vous y êtes vous y êtes
sensible et puis pour les entreprises de
notre pays donc il y a vraiment une
série de de cible de population cibles
sur lesquelles nous devons travailler
aujourd'hui et c'est bien moi le sens de
ma candidature c'est d'être un élu local
connaissant bien les enjeux les
difficultés mais aussi je crois les
possibilités le potentiel de la
transition écologique au niveau du
territoire
candidat à la présidence de l'ADEME pour
effectivement accompagné ce mouvement et
le développer l'amplifier encore alors
je vais me permettre de répondre
peut-être plus précisément aux
différentes questions que vous m'avez
adressées première et le concerne la
situation des effectifs de la dame
ou statistiquement et la comptablement
il faut juste effectivement bien
considéré que on est revenu à une
situation que nous avions connue en
termes en termes d'effectif alors ça
puisque il y a une bonne nouvelle avec
le relèvement du plafond d'emploi de 90
TP en 2023 mais c'est vrai que ça ne
fait que rattraper une partie de la
décroissance que nous nous l'organisme
l'agence avait connu depuis 2014
néanmoins
dans le contexte budgétaire dans lequel
nous sommes je crois qu'il faut
apprécier cette cette dotation
supplémentaire moi j'aurais à cœur dans
les dans les semaines qui viennent de
vérifier cette adéquation entre les
missions qui nous sont confiées
effectivement et les moyens qui sont qui
sont alloués nous sommes un
établissement public gouverné par
effectivement un plafond d'emploi et
donc je vais parce que c'est je crois
vraiment l'intérêt profond de l'agence
et de la mission qui me
ici vous en décidez ainsi me serait
confié et bien vérifier qu'il y a
adéquation qu'il y a justement nous
avons les moyens que l'on donne les
moyens en effectif suffisant
on peut malgré tout d'ores et déjà
constaté que que l'ADEME ces dernières
années justement parce que les effectifs
a eu tendance à se réduire à super un
certain nombre d'efforts pas seulement
le nombre et les effectifs disponibles
je crois que la dame a beaucoup
travaillé sur les systèmes d'information
beaucoup travailler effectivement sur le
fait d'avoir une meilleure fluidité une
meilleure ergonomie dans le temps de
traitement des dossiers c'est
naturellement extrêmement important on
imagine bien que si les saisies
manuelles se multiplient dans
l'instruction des dossiers et bien on
perd un temps précieux et et finalement
des activités qui sont pas
extraordinairement utiles à l'objet
social de l'agence donc on a je crois
encore des marges à explorer en termes
d'organisation de de coopération aussi
j'y reviendrai ça n'est naturellement
pas la même chose si dans les années qui
viennent nous anticipons un large
mouvement de contractualisation avec les
régions sur les fonds chaleurs et
économie circulaire comme comme vous
l'avez mentionné ça naturellement bien
sûr impacté les moyens dont nous aurons
besoin mais soyez pour vous rassurer je
veux vraiment vous exprimer la
détermination qu'il a mienne à de
manière tout à fait prioritaire et dans
les premières semaines
qu'elles échéant de du mandat qui me
serait confié de vérifier de faire le
tour notamment en rendant sur le terrain
dans les différentes directions
régionales y compris en outre-mer pour
vérifier que nous avons aujourd'hui
effectivement les moyens d'agir et si
d'aventure je constatais qu'il y avait
des ajustements qui étaient nécessaires
et bien je croyais bien que j'aurai à ce
moment-là le l'engagement de de faire
évoluer les choses
remonter cette difficulté parce que je
crois vraiment que aujourd'hui nous de
nous devons aller vers l'efficacité
c'est là encore la mission ce qui est
attendu de moi à la présidence de cette
agence et donc cette question des
effectifs me préoccupe et me préoccupera
tout autant que que vous l'êtes
sur les nouveaux périmètres alors je
voudrais redire parce que je crois que
ça ça a été aussi et vous parliez tout à
l'heure de la loi 3DS je vais y revenir
peut-être source parfois d'une certaine
incompréhension sur ce qu'est l'action
de de la dame la dame c'est un opérateur
de l'État
nous sommes là pour mettre en œuvre et
politique qui sont confiées par en
l'occurrence le gouvernement et le
Parlement qu'il dotent de moyens
ça signifie que nos périmètres
d'intervention ça n'est pas nous qui les
choisissons on a certes et c'est
extrêmement précieux à l'ADEME une
véritable expertise sur tous les sujets
qu'on a évoqué qui permet d'avoir avec
les trois ministères de tutelle la
transition écologique la transition
énergétique est l'enseignement supérieur
recherche je crois une discussion
intéressante y compris en termes de
stratégie quand le gouvernement élabore
sa stratégie sur le sujet l'économie
circulaire il serait absurde qu'on se
passe des compétences de l'ADEME de
l'expertise de l'ADEME sur ces sujets
donc elles sont ses compétences cette
expertise et je dirais même cette
excursive indépendante ou parler tout à
l'heure effectivement de l'autonomie je
vais y revenir ça c'est un actif je
crois extrêmement précieux qu'il nous
faut à l'avenir préserver ça nous permet
de discuter d'apporter de contribuer au
niveau national je souhaiterais qu'on le
fasse aussi encore davantage au niveau
local via les préfets et les
collectivités mais donc on a ce rôle
d'opérateur qui connaissant
particulièrement bien les sujets peut
avec cet hôtel interagir elle est
apportée je crois des choses à la
définition des politiques mais nous ne
choisissons pas les périmètres qui nous
sont qui nous sont alloués et donc je
considère que sur les politiques qui
nous sont confiées nous avons pardon de
les mettre en œuvre que notre objectif
c'est un objectif d'efficacité de
déficience même parce que parce que je
pense que dans le contexte budgétaire
dans lequel nous sommes les moyens que
nous utilisons pour atteindre nos
objectifs sont importants comme partout
mais donc nous considère vraiment moi
que que la mission qui me serait
éventuellement confiée c'est de
tenir les engagements de rapporter
régulièrement par rapport aux objectifs
qui sont ceux du fond chaleur du fond
économie circulaire du fond des
carbonations industrielles qui est très
puissamment doté comme vous le savez par
le programme France 2030 et
tous ces sujets là et bien on a délivré
apporté des résultats et en rendre
compte au gouvernement et au Parlement
alors cette soucis d'efficacité il doit
effectivement nous conduire vous le
souligner je ne peux vraiment qui
souscrit à éviter toute forme de
concurrence et à rechercher une
meilleure cohérence de l'action publique
c'est d'abord vrai vous vous le vous le
disiez vous mentionniez avec un certain
opérateurs d'autres opérateurs de l'État
ou d'opérateur nationaux le cerema bien
sûr qui est un pôle d'ingénierie voilà
dont chacun reconnaît la très grande de
la très grande qualité
j'espère pouvoir rencontrer très
prochainement sa présidente et puis que
que nous
amplifions la coopération qui
aujourd'hui est pas formalisé entre
entre la dame et le cerema mais qui je
crois mérite tout à fait de l'être mais
on pourrait mentionner l'Agence
nationale de la cohésion des territoires
on pourrait aussi bien sûr
parler de BPI France et peut-être encore
de beaucoup d'autres organismes qui avec
lesquels il me semble qu'il est qu'il
était indispensable que nous ayons
finalement des conventions qui encadrent
notre coopération et qu'on est au-delà
de ça au lieu de convention eu une vraie
coopération et des rapprochements
réguliers pour nous coordonner sur
l'action
c'est je crois cette concurrence aussi
et il faut que nous y réfléchissions sur
dans la coordination entre l'action de
l'État et et des collectivités locales
moi je suis en ce moment et si c'est un
mandat que je quitterai en cas de si je
prends la présidence de l'ADEME
vice-président de la région Grand Est en
charge du développement économique
et quand je lis ce qui est aujourd'hui
le programme de l'ADEME que sont les
modalités d'action que nous avons sur le
fond des carbonations industrielles
c'est-à-dire faire des diagnostics
proposés des diagnostics sensibilisés
pas simplement les très grands émetteurs
là les 50 qui ont été réunis il y a
quelques semaines à l'Élysée mais les
26000 PMI de France qui qui ont besoin
de s'engager elle aussi dans la
transition énergétique bien je lis les
modalités donc on fait des diagnostics
et puis ensuite sur les programmes
d'investissement des carbonation on
apporte on mobilise des fonds publics
pour aider ces entreprises à faire ces
investissements le plus rapidement
possible et bien Gilly les mêmes
modalités d'intervention que ce que je
sais être mis en place en ce moment en
région Grand Est ce que je sais par
région de France être mis en place dans
les 12 autres régions métropolitaines au
moins donc
se pose la question de savoir si on va
tous aller travailler à la décarbonation
industrielle de notre pays en ordre
dispersé ou si on essaie au contraire
plutôt de coordonner les choses l'argent
public étant quand même particulièrement
rare en ce moment j'ai une petite
préférence pour la seconde option et je
crois que je crois aujourd'hui
ce que vous indiquez effectivement
l'idée de d'éviter cette concurrence et
bien il nous faut vraiment y travailler
entre opérateurs de l'État avec les
services de l'État je reviendrai sur le
la question de relation avec les préfets
et puis aussi avec les collectivités
territoriales et je crois voilà pouvoir
dire que comme élu local c'est quelque
chose qui me qui me qui me parle
particulièrement parce que on
a vraiment le besoin sur un sujet aussi
essentiel que la transition écologique
est bien d'être tous de travailler tous
dans un cadre cohérent
vous vous avez effectivement
relevé l'évolution que que la loi 3DS
apporte
au fonctionnement de l'ADEME dans les
territoires avec ce le préfet qui
devient alors comme
c'est pas pour banaliser le sujet je
vais y revenir je pense que ça c'est
tout au fond sauf banal et anodin ce qui
s'est passé avec la loi 3DS il faut
qu'on en comprenne complètement le sens
à l'ADEME d'ailleurs un message qu'il
faudra que j'ai aussi si le cas échéant
avec avec les les cadres avec les
personnels de l'ADEME mais le préfet
délégué territorial c'est le cas par
exemple pour l'Agence nationale de
rénovation urbaine que je vois
fonctionner dans mon territoire et je
sais que fonctionne dans d'autres sans
que ça pose des difficultés majeures
néanmoins c'est une évolution importante
pour l'ADEME qui a longtemps eu
effectivement une autonomie de gestion
beaucoup plus grande
est-ce que cette autonomie de gestion ne
s'est pas accompagner c'est l'hypothèse
que je fais de quelques maladresses dans
le fonctionnement dans l'articulation
dans la cohérence au niveau territorial
j'ai tendance à le penser parce que je
crois que ce qui s'est passé que la loi
3DS c'est aussi une réaction
pour le coup de des services de service
de l'État et notamment du corps
préfectoral qui dans un certain nombre
de cas ont pu ont dû pouvoir pointer que
telle déléguer territoriale de l'ADN ou
tel service conduisait des opérations
qui n'avaient pas complètement
connaissance et que la cohérence de
l'action de l'État la dame est un
opérateur de l'État au niveau local
était mise à mal par ces ce mode de
fonctionnement donc on a je crois mis en
place un dispositif qui va remettre très
clairement le l'ADEME au niveau
territorial sous sous l'autorité du
préfet et pour moi aujourd'hui ça
constitue ça la loi ça constitue notre
principe de fonctionnement et il faut
que nous en tir tous les avantages que
ça représente là encore parler de
cohérence tout à l'heure je pense
qu'effectivement au niveau local les
préfets qui ont qui ont signé avec les
territoires les contrats de relance et
transition écologique connaissent on la
connaissance d'un très grand nombre de
de projets des collectivités qui vont
absolument dans ce sens de la transition
écologique et bien je crois que au-delà
de respecter la loi 3DS l'ADEME
aujourd'hui doit devenir un pôle
d'expertise et et finalement de d'aide
de proposition à destination des préfets
des préfets de régions et préfets de
départements parce que il me semble que
c'est pas simplement ce que la loi nous
prescrit mais simplement même ce que
l'exigence de cohérence de l'action
publique nous demande de faire donc je
crois qu'il n'y a il n'y a pas
s'agissant d'un opérateur de l'État
redouté particulièrement de main mise
sur le sur le fonctionnement je serais
moi comme président attaché à ce que la
dame garde son autonomie de gestion
c'est c'est je crois bien aussi
l'autonomie de gestion ça suscite des
initiatives ça permet
certainement d'aller plus rapidement sur
sur certains sujets mais qu'il nous faut
respecter le cadre institutionnel qui
nous est donné là encore parce que parce
que je crois qu'il est un cadre de bon
sens et qu'il rejoint une préoccupation
que nous avons tous qui a quand même de
voir l'état assez différentes
ces différents instruments ou outils
agir de manière coordonnée y compris au
niveau local je pense que là pour le
maire que je suis c'est pas mal aussi
qu'il y ait un interlocuteur en
l'occurrence le préfet et que l'ensemble
des opérateurs de l'État soient
finalement rangés derrière lui
sur la décentralisation
je partage bien sûr vraiment ce que ce
que vous évoquez moi je suis
à titre personnel tout à fait convaincu
que
grosse partie des sujets de transition
et écologique se joue va se jouer dans
chacun de nos territoires et notamment
dans la capacité effectivement des élus
à expliquer à entraîner on a on
travaille beaucoup
c'est assez logique sur le
l'acceptabilité sociale d'un certain
nombre de changements c'est que la
sobriété énergétique ça n'est pas
seulement un sujet simple et qui se
résume à quelques réglages de
température quand on touche à
l'évolution des mobilités ou plus
durablement à la structuration de
l'habitat la périurbanisation on est sur
des sujets qui touchent très vite des
enjeux fondamentaux de nos concitoyens
je crois que c'est vraiment le rôle et
l'honneur des des élus locaux de notre
pays et bien que de participer à cette
explication à cette
sensibilisation aux enjeux et donc
effectivement je crois que le rôle d'un
opérateur de l'État comme l'ADEME c'est
vraiment d'être au côté des territoires
qui sont sur la ligne de front de cette
transition de cette transition
écologique de leur apporter des moyens
des solutions et donc je crois vraiment
qu'il fait partie de la mission qui qui
me serait confiée d'être dans cette
territorialisation encore accrue de
l'ADEME alors la loi permet de
travailler avec les régions sur
la délégation donc du fond chaleur et et
du fond économie circulaire mais je
crois que qu'il nous faut aller encore
au delà et que la dame soit présente en
soutien auprès des autres territoires
inférieurs enfin inférieur en dessous du
infra région plutôt
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale c'est parce que c'est
souvent à ce niveau là que les choses se
mettent en place et je crois là encore
que le cadre qui a été posé parfois
suscité un peu de de scepticisme qui est
celui des CRPE doit peut-être nous
permettre avec une vraie présence de la
dame aux côtés des élus de les
accompagner sur l'ingénierie et sur le
financement de tous ces projets de
transition écologique je terminerai si
vous m'avez interrogé aussi sur sur la
loi Haget et ses conséquences il s'agit
pour nous effectivement d'une extension
de de compétences significative mais
tout à fait
tout à fait naturel et et de notre point
de vue évidente là je crois comprendre
mais à la lecture de l'organigramme des
organisations qui est celle aujourd'hui
de l'ADEME que nous avons fait entre
guillemets notre part du chemin en
constituant au sein de l'agence une
direction de la supervision des des de
la responsabilité des producteurs
étendus des producteurs et aujourd'hui
on est en train d'essayer encore par la
voix amiable mais de trouver une
solution au blocage de des
éco-organismes qui sur le versement des
redevances qui vont nous permettre ce
financement il y a un budget annexe qui
était mis en place et qui aujourd'hui
n'est pas alimenté par les redevances
qui ont été institués pourtant par la
loi et donc on a
à reprendre une démarche dans un premier
temps diplomatique et amiable avec ses
différents éco-organismes mais quand
même falloir que la loi s'applique et je
vous confirme que si si ça n'était pas
le cas la dame ne pourrait pas laisser
ce sujet en l'état et et que au-delà
effectivement de recevoir les ressources
pour assurer les missions je crois
effectivement que la surveillance du bon
fonctionnement de cette de CRF de ces
responsabilités étendues des producteurs
et est un sujet essentiel de l'économie
circulaire en métropole mais encore
peut-être davantage dans les territoires
d'outre-mer ou le sujet des déchets
d'ailleurs je crois un rapport
sénatorial vient de le pointer encore
tout récemment et particulièrement en
criant important et donc nous saurons
faire preuve à la fois là de fermeté et
puis de toutes les capacités
d'initiatives pour pour obtenir que que
ce sujet vient finalement soit soit
traité par l'ADEME comme législateur
entendu le faire dans la loi âgée que
toute récente
voilà j'ai été très long je pense oui
désolé
merci je vais donc donner la parole à
Joël Bigot
merci monsieur le président
chers collègues
monsieur le candidat Monsieur le Maire
et c'est pas par hasard que j'emploie ce
mot
ça n'est pas faute d'avoir interpellé à
plusieurs reprises le gouvernement sur
cette vacance de la présidente de
l'ADEME provoquée par le départ anticipé
d'Arnaud Leroy en juin dernier que nous
avons aujourd'hui beaucoup de plaisir à
vous recevoir membre du CEA de l'ADEM
j'ai pu constater que cette vacances de
la dame qui a duré quand même six mois a
créé des inquiétudes et j'étais une
certaine confusion dans les services de
cet instant la DM c'est le premier
opérateur de l'État pour la transition
écologique à l'heure de la sobriété
générale pour nos concitoyens et pour
les collectivités territoriales et
durant l'examen du projet de loi de
finance qui s'achève il lui était
judicieux et profitable d'avoir un
président de l'ADEME qui puisse porter
une voie singulière dans le débat
budgétaire cette page est maintenant
derrière nous mais je le voyais quand
même le dire
pour la seconde année les moyens de
l'ADEME sont en hausse Martin de Sidrac
l'a dit tout à l'heure une hausse de 46
millions d'euros passant de 164 à 210
millions on va pas s'échapper sur les
chiffres je pense que c'est ça néanmoins
cette augmentation de budget qu'il faut
saluer ne doit pas dissimuler certaines
baisses de crédit comme ceux dédié au
fond de prévention des risques naturels
dit fond Barnier en dernier lieu n'est
pas sûr que cette augmentation soit à la
hauteur des nouvelles missions d'évolu à
l'ADEME par la loi GEC notamment avec la
supervision des nouvelles filières rept
vous en avez vous l'avez abordé dans
votre propos liminaire par ailleurs ça a
été souligné également par Martin de
Sylvain qui a un véritable enjeu
d'emploi public à l'ADEME même si
certains postes sont créés on constate
clairement que les effectifs sont
quasiment constants depuis 2009 alors
que les crédits à pilotés sont de plus
en plus importants l'ADEME recrute donc
des intérimaires qui sont en incapacité
de suivre les dossiers sur le long terme
ce qui n'est pas bon pour notre
ingénierie d'État pour le aussi des
projets des collectivités territoriales
je pense que vous avez conscience de
cette problématique et que vous pourrez
nous répondre sur ce sujet
depuis la loi 3DS que vous avez abordé
également nous avons compris que le
gouvernement souhaite reprendre en main
voir recadrer le mot de moi la dame sous
la houlette des préfets de régions mais
vous l'avez esquissé et votre propos est
sans ambiguïté effectivement l'ADM a eu
trop d'autonomie il convient de moi je
dis recadrer vous avez d'autres termes
pour le qualifier Christophe Béchu
expliquait récemment dans la Gazette des
communes que la nomination du nouveau
patron de la dame offrirait l'occasion
d'avoir des feuilles de route de début
de mandat pour les différentes agences
d'ingénierie de l'État en matière de
transition écologique notamment le
céréales le serema et la NCT je veux
dire que les élus locaux face à ce
nouveau dispositif sont un petit peu
perdus
ils ont on a le sentiment que le il va
falloir une période d'adaptation
jusqu'ici le fonctionnement de l'ADEME
offrait quand même une certaine
souplesse qui permettait de consommer
tous les crédits voire de l'erreur
réorienter au cours de l'année
quelque chose j'étais au conseil
d'administration là ça risque d'être un
fonctionnement plus en silo et ça il
risque d'y avoir sans doute des
enveloppes qui ne seront pas consommées
donc quel est votre vision de
l'articulation entre l'ADEME la NCT le
céréma et l'état des concentrés
avez-vous connaissance des feuilles de
route qui évoquent le ministre de la
transition écologique et puis il y a un
autre point d'importance que je crois
qu'il faut qu'on traite dans mon propos
liminaire je vous ai qualifié Monsieur
le Maire
pourquoi parce que le précédent
président de l'ADEME avait une fonction
à temps plein à l'ADEME vous êtes maire
vous allez vous avez dit que vous alliez
démissionner de vos fonctions à la
région comptez-vous démissionner de vos
mandats électriques à la mairie ou à
l'agglomération de Charleville-Mézières
pour vous consacrer entièrement à votre
tâche de président de Région de pardon
de la première agence écologique de
l'État quel sera votre décision si
d'aventure ce n'était pas le cas je
crois que ça inddurait véritablement un
changement de fonction de paradigme pour
la présidence de l'ADEME qui deviendrait
le bras armé des décisions de l'État
central pour faire appliquer les
décisions donc pour connaître la dame de
l'intérieur je peux vous dire que dans
une période où les élus ont besoin de
tout le soutien nécessaire à leur projet
ça me paraît fondamental
enfin dernier point comme vous le savez
sûrement je vais m'arrêter là après la
dame a publié en 2021 4 scénarii pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone en 2050
ces scénaris prévoit tous une part
importante d'électricité renouvelable
avez-vous pu en prendre connaissance et
penchez-vous plus particulièrement pour
l'un de ces scénarios je vous remercie
merci
la parole à Didier mandeli puis après
vous répondre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
candidat je voudrais tout d'abord dire
que pour ce qui me concerne et je pense
que nous sommes nombreux à le penser moi
je n'ai aucun doute sur la fois vos
compétences sur votre appétence pour la
fonction et demain sur votre efficacité
à conduire
ou rediriger au président
ma question elle est plutôt dans un
contexte enfin j'ai plusieurs questions
j'en ai deux dont une qui rejoint celle
de mon collègue qui vient de s'exprimer
Joël
on est dans un contexte où le président
de la République vient de nommer ou
désigner depuis quelques semaines
quelques mois un grand nombre de
personnalités à la tête de différents
organismes nous avons eu bien sûr pour
succéder à Christophe Béchu devenu
ministre à la fuite Jean Castex qui
quelques semaines plus tard abandonne
Lafitte pour prendre la présidence de la
ATP nous aurons dans quelques jours une
ou quelques semaines l'audition d'un
candidat à la présidence de Lafitte pour
succéder en Castex nous vous
auditionnons aujourd'hui
j'ai une question simple on sait comment
se déroule ce genre de candidature ou
désignation
et j'ai du mal à comme sans doute
beaucoup à traduire la pensée du
président de la République où l'objectif
ou les objectifs
dans le cadre de ces désignations est-ce
que il s'agit
ouais je vais vous dire que les choses
comme je le pense est-ce qu'il s'agit de
d'une récompense pour avoir fait
allégeance avoir fait un pas dans la
direction du président de la République
est-ce qu'il s'agit
pour le président de la République de
dire je fais confiance aux élus locaux
qui ont fait leurs preuves à
Charleville-Mézières à Dunkerque et
peut-être ailleurs
moi j'ai du mal à déceler mais cette
pensée complexe
donc voilà je suis pas sûr que vous
puissiez me répondre voilà mais
j'aimerais connaître le processus qui
amène j'avais posé la question
Christophe Béchu quand il était désigné
pour pour la fuite j'ai posé à peu près
le même genre de questions à Jean Castex
moi j'aimerais pour nous concitoyens et
les élus les choses soient claires
et là encore je reviens sur ce que j'ai
dit en préambule il s'agit pas c'est pas
du tout personnel sur ni compétences ni
appétence et puis ma question en fait en
filigrane c'était aussi comme Joël de me
dire la présidence de l'ADEME qui est un
organisme effectivement c'est le bras
mais de l'État pour mettre en oeuvre les
politiques comme d'autres leçons comme
la fit etc et si on est bien conscient
et à mon sens ça nécessite un engagement
permanent quotidien et pour avoir été
pour ce qui me concerne dans des
dimensions différentes mais merde d'une
commune de 9000 habitants président
d'une intercote 42000 et sénateurs en
même temps pendant quelques mois très
vite j'ai laissé mes fonctions de mer et
très vite la loi est arrivée ensuite en
2017 mais je me suis rendu compte que si
on voulait faire correctement les choses
au niveau national et local il fallait
quelquefois faire des choix des d'avoir
des priorités et donc ma question elle
rejoint celle de joie c'est vous êtes
maire de Charleville-Mézières une ville
chère à mon cœur j'y suis né juste à
côté et j'ai encore de de la famille
présente dans cette ville et vous avez
été réduit brillamment les gens vous
apprécient
j'imagine que ce sera un crève-cœur si
vous devez demain quitter cette fonction
mais en même temps président de l'Agglo
enfin moi ça me paraît pas compatible
aujourd'hui de cumuler toutes ces
fonctions ce sont pas des fonctions
collectives comme un parlementaire mais
mais en tout cas même si vous nous avez
indiqué vous alliez quitté la région
voilà donc ça c'est c'est ma question
mais je pense que beaucoup se pose ce
genre de questions notre souci notre
interrogation c'est vraiment de donner
la pleine mesure à la fonction dans le
cadre parce que c'est un c'est un bel
outil et qui est utile pour pour les
élocaux comme pour chacun nos
concitoyens donc j'attends vos réponses
sur ces questions merci
il me semble que dans le contexte
d'urgence écologique climatique dans
lequel nous sommes les choses devraient
pouvoir s'organiser assez vite et la
remobilisation si besoin était se faire
se faire très rapidement j'en profite
pour dire que je crois vraiment que le
fait de travailler à l'ADEME c'est un
privilège c'est c'est une chance et que
pour tous ceux qui rejoignent les
services de de l'ADEME parfois comme
intérimaire parfois effectivement comme
contractuel au départ c'est une belle
expérience qui est toujours extrêmement
valorisante pour l'heure pour leur CV
qu'ils y restent ou qu'ils évoluent
ensuite vers d'autres postes donc je
crois que on a on a bien sûr à essayer
de de stabiliser les effectifs vous
l'avez dit on y est aujourd'hui je pense
que dans les années qui viennent si nous
voulons effectivement que la dame puisse
accomplir ses missions il faudra qu'on
ait régulièrement des discussions sur le
niveau du plafond d'emploi c'est indiqué
je répondais tout à l'heure à madame le
rapporteur en disant que ce sera
vraiment pour moi la priorité si ma
nomination est confirmée de vérifier
dans les toutes premières semaines par
des déplacements sur place par le
travail avec les différents services que
nous avons bien aujourd'hui les moyens
d'accomplir les missions qui nous sont
qui nous sont confiées et je pense
qu'effectivement ce souci d'être doté
des moyens doit nous conduire à
réfléchir aux statut des de ceux qui qui
travaillent à l'ADEME je pense que
il y a pas
je crois que c'est on n'a pas entretenir
une précarité excessive sur le sur les
personnes qui qui collaborent à ces
missions se sont des emplois permanents
on n'est pas dans le cadre de au
strictosensus de la fonction publique
territoriale mais en face d'emploi
permanent il est de fonction permanente
il est toujours mieux de effectivement
des emplois qui le sont aussi
sur la question de la souplesse et du
fonctionnement en silo alors là
honnêtement si si
l'évolution de la loi 3DS devaient nous
conduire à compartimenter et à
revenir ou sur
un fonctionnement vraiment silo ce
serait je crois le contraire de ce que
législateur a voulu c'est si si il y a
un sens à cette disposition c'est
vraiment bien qu'au niveau local on est
au contraire plus de cohérence et c'est
moi dans cette dans cette esprit là que
que je pense qu'il faut faire vivre les
dispositions aujourd'hui l'ADEME doit
être au niveau local vraiment le pôle
d'expertise et de et de soutien et
d'accompagnement de la transition
écologique dont le dont le préfet et
l'un des acteurs majeurs avec les
collectivités donc il doit y avoir
vraiment y avoir un travail
quot bien hebdomadaire de coopération
entre les délégations et les directions
régionales et les services de l'État
donc je crois au-delà de
distance de contre ça qui aujourd'hui
quand même dans des processus de
signature électronique ça se gère on est
quand même on imagine plus des
camionnettes de parapheur avec les
chèques de l'ADEME à destination des
collectivités ou des entreprises c'est
quand même plus comme ça qu'on
fonctionne fort heureusement et donc je
pense qu'on doit pouvoir arriver à à
concilier le respect de la loi parce que
c'est indiscutable et là encore je crois
que cette évolution elle elle n'est pas
arrivée de manière anodine ou par hasard
et puis la souplesse effectivement une
souplesse de gestion et et une facilité
de une réactivité plus exactement dans
les dans la réponse aux sollicitations
des entreprises et des collectivités qui
me semblent essentielles
un peu évoqué tout à l'heure le sujet du
serema et de la NCT mais je pense que
sur avec ces organismes nous devons nous
coordonner ils ont alors le céréma une
compétence extrêmement pointue sur un
certain nombre de domaines et en matière
de d'ingénierie pour la destination des
collectivités la NCT a du soutien de
l'ingénierie également mais ni l'un ni
l'autre de ces organismes non
aujourd'hui à leur disposition des fonds
comme ceux dont nous disposons pour
accompagner concrètement les projets et
je crois peut-être pas non plus sans
leur sans leur faire insultes les
capacités de l'expertise que nous avons
sur les thématiques qui nous ont été
confiées et depuis parfois plusieurs
décennies donc on va devoir travailler
avec eux pour bien s'articuler mais il
me semble que
ça n'est ça n'est pas de manière abusive
que l'agence
ADEME peut se dire agence de la
transition écologique c'est c'est elle
en est effectivement le principal
opérateur et elle doit à ce titre
effectivement conclure des conventions
les accords de partenariat de
fonctionnement concertés avec ceux qui
peuvent aider une partie des de ce vers
qui se tourne ses moyens de transition
écologique en l'occurrence s'agit des
collectivités alors vous me posez cette
question et
également sur le sur la question de de
l'engagement comme président de l'ADEME
moi je suis tout à fait conscient d'être
candidat à une fonction d'action et
absolument pas à une fonction de
représentation
c'est tout à fait clair et donc je peux
vous dire d'ici il y avait toute la
solennité que revêt cet engagement
devant la représentation nationale que
vous êtes que je serai un président à
plein temps de la dame je surbrais
pleinement si vous en décidez ainsi si
les deux assemblées en décident ainsi
pleinement l'émission qui qui est
envisagée de me confier et qui sont des
missions effectivement d'action
je suis convaincu et c'est un débat
finalement qui prolonge le débat les
débats qu'on peut avoir parfois sur
l'intérêt ou les inconvénients du cumul
des mandats je suis convaincu que je
serai un bien meilleur président de
l'ADEME je serai un bien meilleur
président de l'ADEME en restant mer
et on connait de ça on est en sur le
terrain auprès de des collègues dans la
mise en oeuvre sur la encore ce que je
disais tout à l'heure la ligne de front
des de l'action territoriale qu'on ne
l'est pas
et donc c'est pour moi au-delà de
l'attachement que je peux avoir à un
moment délit qui était maire
effectivement imagine bien le lien de
confiance fort qui qui existe
aujourd'hui entre les Carolos macéiens
et moi mais mais je pense vraiment que
ce il s'agit là plutôt d'une synergie de
quelque chose d'utile et ben je serai
effectivement maire sur mon temps
personnel avec des équipes qui depuis 8
ans fonctionne qui sont installés à la
fois techniquement dans les directions
de la ville et de l'agglomération et
puis surtout une équipe d'élus un
collectif d'élus qui travaille à mes
côtés et qui me permettent de d'avancer
de fonctionner je crois vraiment
aujourd'hui que
le sujet de président a plein temps de
l'ADEME n'en n'est pas un je serai
j'assumerai totalement ses missions et
je serai notamment aussi présent que
l'était Arnaud Leroy déjà pris des
dispositions
en ce sens pour m'organiser le cas
échéant bien sûr afin d'être comme il
l'était une partie de la semaine présent
à Paris à Angers dans les différents
sites de de l'ADEME et puis
et ça
ça relève entre guillemets aussi de ma
responsabilité de continuer moi sur le
temps qui me restera et bien à être le
maire de de Charleville-Mézières et
président de l'agglomération alors si
pas quelqu'un de borné si je voyais
effectivement que les choses étaient à
l'avenir difficile je pourrais pour
imaginer on pourrait imaginer les
évolutions mais mais très honnêtement je
pense aujourd'hui que c'est que c'est
plutôt un atout pour la fonction que je
à laquelle je suis candidat devant vous
que qu'aujourd'hui un inconvénient et en
toute état de cause moi je prends
absolument l'engagement d'être un à
plein temps de l'ADEME ça c'est tout à
fait clair
merci je vais donner une petite question
sur transition 2050 voilà je voulais pas
oublier ce que c'est alors je crois que
c'est un travail extrêmement utile
extrêmement important on a pu y voir
dans les commentaires des choses qui
notamment sur le la question le débat
énergies renouvelable nucléaire enfin on
est parfois ça parfois ce travail a
parfois été le support d'une polémique à
mon sens pas tout à fait
justifié ce que ce que permet vraiment
surtout ce travail là c'est de montrer
qu'il n'y a pas qu'une seule manière
d'atteindre l'objectif de neutralité
carbone que alors ils ont 2050 on a
effectivement plusieurs voix qui peuvent
permettre d'y parvenir et que c'est ces
différentes voies elles nous expose à
des risques et à des difficultés qui
sont différentes mais qui finalement
ensuite relève des choix démocratiques
qui est donc
qui doivent être faits très clairement
on a dans les scénarios un peu polaires
il y en a un qui est effectivement très
axé sur la sobriété énormément de
sobriété donc énormément de de réduction
y compris des déplacements de
consommation de produits carnés avec des
conséquences importantes fortes sur
votre devis sur aussi sur sur
l'étalement urbain sur l'habitat puis à
l'autre extrémité le scénario 4 qui lui
fait clairement le pari d'une de d'un
recours à des technologies de
séquestration du carbone
qui sont enfin Paris qui aussi tout à
fait risqué et compliqué aujourd'hui en
l'état actuel de des évolutions
technologiques donc on a je crois que
c'est ça vraiment l'intérêt de de ce
travail là et puis de montrer qu'il y a
malgré tout des invariants dans dans ces
différents scénarios notamment l'un qui
touche au développement des énergies
renouvelables on a dans tous les cas à
agir massivement pour le développement
des énergies renouvelables et et donc
développement du nucléaire un corps qui
moi ne personnel et de pose absolument
aucun souci en plus c'est aujourd'hui la
direction prise par l'État et donc c'est
une donnée et mais au-delà et bien nous
avons et ça en revanche c'est la mission
de l'ADEME à nous donner tous les moyens
de
de via notamment le fond chaleur de
développer cette chaleur renouvelable la
chaleur c'est 40% notre notre
consommation
énergétique finale donc c'est il y a la
question de la production d'électricité
mais la question de la production de
chaleur et est également un sujet
fondamental et là l'agence avec le fond
dont elle dispose donc je sais que le
Sénat est vigilant ce qu'il soit
convenablement doté voire même qu'il
augmente le disait un instant le
rapporteur et bien on va on va continuer
à agir et à développer les énergies
renouvelables dans cette dans ce secteur
effectivement notamment de la production
de chaleur voilà pardon j'ai essayé
d'être complet
merci je suis dans la parole à Hervé
gilet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
candidat j'ai écouté avec beaucoup
d'attention les réponses que vous avez
apportées à nos collègues et j'ai
toujours des interrogations qui sont
assez fortes je voudrais revenir sur la
gouvernance
vous nous confirmez donc au travers de
vos propos que vous serez comme Arnaud
Leroy donc Président Directeur Général
donc nous assumerez la fonction de
président et de directeur général
ce qui veut dire là pour le coup
effectivement un engagement
conséquent
qui était donc à hauteur d'ailleurs des
évoluments car nous Leroy pouvait
percevoir dans cette mission et dans ce
travail donc effectivement les
interrogations qui ont été portées
semblent tout à fait légitimes par
rapport à vos engagements également
politiques qui nécessiteront pour vous
aussi malgré tout du temps et donc pour
ma part je reste très interrogatif je
pensais qu'il y aurait une évolution de
la gouvernance c'est-à-dire qu'il y
aurait un président un directeur général
un directeur général adjoint comme il
existait précédemment et vous nous
confirmez aujourd'hui que ce ne sera pas
le cas vous serez bien président et
directeur général donc je voulais
vraiment vous faire part de ma surprise
par rapport à ça et revenir donc
effectivement sur ce sujet le deuxième
point que je voulais aborder
c'est j'ai manqué de clés de lecture par
rapport à votre approche en termes de
contractualisation et de
décentralisation je m'explique
certes on entend bien les relations qui
devraient s'approfondir avec les régions
et au travers de la loi 3DS la
nécessaire relation qualitéive a établie
aussi avec les services de l'État plus
particulièrement les préfets mais on ne
voit pas comment vous percevez la
prostéritoriale et notamment la nouvelle
loi énergie renouvelable accélération
des énergies renouvelables mettez en
perspective l'échelon territorial les
scottes par exemple comme des
territoires aussi d'appréhension et de
mise en oeuvre des politiques à la fois
climatiques et énergétiques donc
j'aimerais vous entendre sur sur ce
sujet vous avez parlé des EPCI mais il
me semble qu'il faut les inscrire plus
dans des logiques de territoire et pour
sortir de la logique d'appel à projet de
l'ADEME qui parfois était dénoncé
d'ailleurs comme un peu trop forte ou
comment consommer vous une
accompagnement plutôt dans des
trajectoires peut-être plus linéaire en
termes de temporalité avec des approches
peut-être plus contractualisées
aujourd'hui et enfin pour terminer
quelle vision avec vous de la
complémentarité d'action avec l'État
notamment sur la mise en oeuvre du fond
vert je vous remercie
merci merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
candidat parmi les sujets de transition
écologique que l'ADEME à connaître et
qui ont été rappelés à la fois par
vous-même et par mes collègues il en est
un qui n'a pas été évoqué ce matin mais
dans lequel la dame est au cœur du
réacteur si vous me permettez cette
expression c'est celui-là le
territorialisation de notre alimentation
notamment les fameux projets
alimentaires territoriaux sujets que
notre commission a eu à connaître avec
certains de mes collègues puisque nous
avons travaillé sur le sujet et dans ce
domaine force de constater que
compétences et expertise sont reconnues
de manière unanime et pourquoi
sont-elles reconnues de manière unanime
puisque ça vient d'être appelé à
l'instant par notre collègue gilet et
pardon si ma question risque d'être un
peu redondante mais je pense que c'est
important on voit bien que la transition
écologique c'est bien évidemment
l'affaire de l'État mais c'est d'abord
et avant tout la faire des territoires
et je pense qu'il y a un appel récent
dans le monde quand on parle d'énergie
qui nous le rappelle avec 160 et lui qui
signent et on voit bien que les
implantations locales de l'ADEME sont
aujourd'hui ce qui fait la force de
l'ADEME avec cette synergie qui s'opère
entre les acteurs sur le terrain les
collectivités et les opérateurs donc ma
question est simple dans votre feuille
de route est-ce que la pérennisation et
le renforcement qui sont je pense une
nécessité de ces antennes locales figure
au rang de priorité des priorités merci
voilà Monsieur Jacques ferrique et
Madame variaas
oui merci le président
merci de de vos explications de votre
présentation vous avez souligné le rôle
majeur des des territoires dans dans la
transition écologique
d'une certaine façon je dirais qu'on est
dans une phase de transition à
l'intérieur de la transition puisqu'on
on passe de l'époque des des territoires
pionniers vous avez dit le rôle pionnier
de votre collectivité sur sur le plan
vélo qui est effectivement assez
remarquable sur la question des déchets
on passe de l'époque des collectivités
pionnières à une généralisation de
l'implication des différentes
territoires dans la transition
c'est clair qu'avec on le voit avec les
responsables
ce qu'auront à faire les uns et les
autres avec la dans le prolongement de
la loi d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables le fond vert la question
des etfan
ceci dit on est dans une problématique
budgétaire pour les collectivités qui
risquent quoi qu'on en dise malgré filet
de sécurité autre dispositif de quand
même se traduire par un
affaiblissement des investissements même
si les affichages resteront peut-être
les taux de réalisation risque de
fléchir sérieusement donc dans ce
contexte quelle stratégie de l'ADEME
déjà pour pour dans le meilleur des cas
je dirais contribuer à amplifier cette
généralisation éviter aussi que cette
généralisation parce que c'est un peu
toujours ce qui se passe dans ces cas-là
ne se traduisent par un aphaddissement
de la qualité de la transition et puis
aussi pour réduire parce qu'il y a des
territoires qui ont d'autres priorités
urgentes d'éviter qu'on est l'apparition
singulière de zone blanche de la
transition écologique
moi je ne reviendrai pas sur
vos compétences je ne vous connais pas
monsieur morvignon mais même si je
considère que c'est quand même un
challenge qui s'offre devant vous de
rester mère président de l'Agglo et
d'assumer les compétences que viennent
d'évoquer monsieur gilet à travers à la
fois la présidente et la direction
générale il y a un thème qui me tient à
cœur et sur lequel qui n'a été effleuré
ce matin
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire
aujourd'hui que nous vivons une période
de plus en plus marquée par le
dérèglement climatique avec des impacts
de plus en plus visibles et de fortes
hausses du prix de l'énergie notre parc
dans ce contexte notre parc bâti
représente encore 43% de toute l'énergie
consommée dans notre pays or pour
respecter nos engagements et les
objectifs à atteindre en 2050 nous
devons accélérer les rénovations de nos
logements
et des rénovations performantes en
termes d'économie d'énergie et donc à
lutter efficacement contre la précarité
énergétique dont nous savons que 12
millions de Français en souffrent et que
nous avons aujourd'hui 4,8 millions de
logements qui sont des passoires
thermiques alors si ma prime rénove et
je l'ai bien vécu dans mon mandat local
si ma prime rénove et le programme
habité mieux ont permis l'an dernier de
faire sortir du statut de passoire
thermique de 1500 logements nous savons
que seuls 60000 ont véritablement fait
l'objet d'une rénovation globale alors
que nous savons que c'est au rythme de
plus de 500 000 logements par an qu'il
nous faudra avancer pour être dans les
clous si je puis me permettre l'ADEME a
publié une une étude qu'elle appelait
firéno
financement de la rénovation performante
des logements qui contient une série de
propositions en fait de mettre en place
une politique publique pour accélérer
ces rénovations performantes et qui
au-delà de l'économie énergétique elle
génère son positives pour les ménages en
termes de pouvoir d'achat et de santé et
positive aussi pour les tous les travaux
qu'elle génère par le pour le BTP et de
sur quoi sur des emplois non
délocalisables nous savons très
précisément qu'en termes de santé une
étude a montré que la rénovation de
toutes les passoires thermiques
permettrait aujourd'hui à notre système
de santé d'économiser 700 millions
d'euros par an c'est pas négligeable
donc c'est une si vous voulez c'est une
une thématique sur laquelle je voudrais
savoir comment l'ADEME va monter quels
sont ses moyens pour monter pour être
prêt des collectivités le territoriales
auprès des élus qu'elle suites vous
entendez donner à cette à cette étude et
de quelle manière vous appréhendez cette
question essentielle en matière de
transition énergétique qui concerne
d'ailleurs aussi le parc des
copropriétés et le parc des logements
sociaux
[Musique]
merci je vous propose de répondre à mes
collègues
merci monsieur le Président alors je
d'abord sur la question de la
gouvernance
il existe effectivement à la DM
aujourd'hui
en fonction de président directeur
général et puis il existe aussi et elle
est également en vacances une fonction
de directeur général délégué
les textes prévoient et permettent
effectivement
au PDG de nommé au moins au moins un
directeur général délégué ce qui était
le cas dans la période récente Fabrice
Boissier ont quitté ses fonctions il est
effectivement tout à fait indispensable
que ce poste soit pourvu et l'ADEME a
toujours fonctionné de cette manière là
avec effectivement un président
Arnaud Leroy est Fabrice Boissier
directeur général délégué qui
travaillait finalement en binôme donc je
mon intention aussi si ma nomination est
confirmée c'est effectivement de pouvoir
rapidement ce poste et d'être capable
assez vite de constituer ou de
reconstituer
une équipe exécutive au delà même de du
binôme PDG directeur général délégué
qui soit tout à fait
opérationnel actives des mouvements
ont pu être annoncé parmi les cadres de
l'agence et je rejoins les
préoccupations je crois exprimées par
plusieurs d'entre vous sur le fait que
il faut que maintenant qu'on stabilise
l'équipe pour qu'elle soit complètement
en ordre de marche
j'en profite pour dire que la question
des émoluments est aussi quelque chose
qui m'a moi surpris je reste un peu
étonné alors non pas sur la composition
de la de la rémunération qu'elle
comporte notamment une part variable
liée à l'atteinte des objectifs me
semble tout à fait sain et vraiment de
de bon aloi c'est le niveau de la partie
socle qui m'a m'interroge je m'interroge
notamment sur le fait que un opérateur
PDG d'un opérateur puisse être sur cette
partie socle mieux rémunérer que ne le
sont ses ministres tutelle
pour moi pas de difficulté à ce qu'il y
ait une remise en ordre de ce sujet est
très concrètement qu'on revoit à la
baisse cette rémunération pour qu'il y
ait quand même un minimum de
hiérarchisation dans dans le
fonctionnement il y a peut-être des
explications que j'ai du mal à saisir
mais je crois pas pourquoi et je vois
pas comment les opérateurs de l'État
peuvent quel que soit les risques entre
guillemets auxquels ils sont exposés
risquent beaucoup de guillemets être
rémunéré mieux que ne le sont les les
ministres auxquels il rapporte
sur le le fonctionnement
territorial je pense que
le lien particulier essentiel que nous
devons développer ça fait partie déjà du
contrat d'objectif et de performance qui
est signé il y a déjà un objectif
aujourd'hui de pour l'agence de nouer
des contacts avec un certain nombre
d'intercommunalités il nous faut encore
aller au-delà effectivement l'objectif
ce serait que la quasi-totalité pour
éviter justement les zones blanches de
la transition écologique la
quasi-totalité des intercommunalités de
notre pays puissent avoir effectivement
eu ce contact cette discussion ce
travail sur
l'approche d'une cohérence globale de la
transition écologique
l'ADEME et les d'ores et déjà très
présentes sur le terrain puisque et elle
est un des premiers financeurs d'un
certain nombre de postes dans les
collectivités il y a énormément de
relais aujourd'hui de d'expertise dans
les politiques et financer par la dame
sur le sujet des déchets notamment mais
sur sur d'autres politiques aussi et je
pense que cette politique là elle doit
être poursuivie pour effectivement qu'on
apporte et qu'on soutienne la
constitution d'une ingénierie alors les
les scottes sont
aussi et dans le cadre de développement
des énergies renouvelables un échelon
pertinent qui peut devenir en tout cas
intéressant et donc ça doit faire partie
des interlocuteurs directs aujourd'hui
de l'ADEME mais sur la question de la
sobriété
foncière et bien je l'ADEME doit se
positionner au niveau local c'est
vraiment je crois le
de la territorialisation que que pour
laquelle je plaide en pôle d'expertise
de ressources et éventuellement donc de
financement de soutien à la mise en
place d'expérience dans ces différentes
collectivités là encore notre notre
rôle à la dance c'est de s'assurer
j'y reviendrai sur la question du du de
l'habitat
que qu'on est effectivement dans cette
démarche de transition écologique dans
une démarche globale et effectivement de
bons niveaux et qu'on n'est pas en train
de faire de la mal adaptation ou de la
malle
transition écologique qui me permettait
ce néologisme en
ne prenant qu'une partie des sujets où
on les traitant partiellement donc
vraiment je crois que c'est ce chantier
là il est devant nous d'aller
effectivement encore davantage en pôle
de ressources et d'expertise et c'est ça
je rejoins tout à fait ce qui a été dit
sur l'importance des délégations
régionales direction régionale de
l'agence c'est déjà une petite moitié
des effectifs de l'agence et si un
mouvement
doit exister et bien c'est effectivement
un mouvement de pour conforter renforcer
ses présences territoriales qui j’ajoute
son son en métropole mais aussi en
outre-mer on a une cinquantaine d'agents
dans les différentes délégations
outre-mer des présences dans les
territoires ou parfois difficiles de
trouver tous les services de l'État je
pense à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon je
pense à la Nouvelle-Calédonie ou à la
Polynésie ce sont des des présences à
laquelle nous tenons beaucoup et qui
sont à mon avis essentiels pour le pour
l'avenir
le travail sur le justement sur
l'alimentation sur les programmes
alimentaires territoriaux là encore je
pense que au niveau au niveau local en
articulation avec ce que
la NCT peut apporter comme soutien à
l'ingénierie et est-ce que les autres
services de l'étape peuvent faire notre
rôle c'est vraiment d'aider à ce que les
collectivités conçoivent des plans des
plantes transition
écologiques aussi cohérent que possible
et et et et Globo et donc je pense que
les différentes questions qui ont été
posées visent tout à ce que l'agence
soit demain via ces délégations encore
plus présentes auprès des différentes
collectivités appelées à participer à la
transition écologique je crois que c'est
d'abord le le niveau intercommunal qui
doit être ciblé le niveau régional lait
et des textes nous permettent
d'intervenir à leur côté et
on a de des projets de coopération qui
sont déjà très investis mais je n'oublie
pas que enfin voilà d'autres d'autres
catégories de d'organismes notamment les
Scotts pourraient bénéficier de ce
soutien sur le fond vert j'avais une
question sur le fond vert et
l'articulation je crois vraiment que le
fond vert si nous voulons que
les moyens considérables qui sont mis là
arrivent rapidement dans les
collectivités pour permettre les
investissements il faut qu'on reste sur
quelque chose de très simple et une
territorialisation via le préfet avec
des dépôts de dossiers avec une sorte de
finalement un peu de guichet unique au
niveau du préfet de département
quelques sujets du fond vert qui sont
explicitement confiées à l'ADEME en
expertise et donc bien je crois le
préfet sera destinataire des des
demandes des propositions de soutien des
collectivités et puis ensuite euh c'est
finalement dans dans la dans le
traitement des dossiers que que les
choses que la dame pourra être amené à
intervenir mais je crois qu'il faut
qu'on tienne bon là-dessus ce serait ce
serait dommage de réfractionner ce fond
et de recréer des différentes voies
d'accès on a un sujet de système
d'information à l'ADEM pour que au
niveau de la saisie d'un certain de de
dossiers on s'évite des ressaisis mais
ce sujet je crois qu'il nous faut le on
va le régler avec les services de l'État
et en toute état de cause c'est quand
même pas mal qui est qui est un point
unique de dépose ça devrait permettre à
ce fond d’être plus rapidement
consommer et mis à d'arriver sur les les
projets des des collectivités je crois
que aujourd'hui avec les la hausse des
prix de l'énergie que subissent la
plupart des collectivités importantes
cette l'attente est extrêmement forte
pour effectivement je terminais sur les
questions d'habitat alors sur les
questions d'habitat
le rôle là encore de
l'ADEME en matière de transition
écologique c'est cette idée les
collectivités de soutenir les
collectivités dans le fait d'avoir une
réflexion globale qui inclut
effectivement ces questions d'habitat
mais vous le savez aussi que sur la mise
en œuvre on a aujourd'hui finalement une
répartition des rôles qui s'est fait
avec l'agence nationale d'amélioration
de l'habitat avec Lana qui vraiment
monte en puissance sur sur cette
question et très honnêtement ça rejoint
une des réponses que j'ai déjà portées
tout à l'heure je crois que je crois que
l'ADEME ne peut pas tout faire elle ne
doit pas tout faire elle ne peut pas
prétendre et être partout sinon elle va
se disperser elle ne sera pas efficace
sur les missions qui lui sont confiées
donc
trouve très bien qu'il y ait finalement
c'est très partition des choses sur la
mise en oeuvre avec avec Lana je crois
que c'est Lana l'expérience
effectivement et je l'ai vécu au niveau
local des programmes habités mieux et
aussi
je crois dispose de moyens importants
pour pour accompagner l'initiative
locale sur la rénovation de l'habitat la
lutte contre les passoires thermiques et
l'accompagnement finalement au ménage
modeste et les plus modestes dans le
dans ce dans cette amélioration
énergétique de leur habitat mais on va
on va garder nous au niveau ADEME dans
le dans le lien et dans les dans les
dans les encore notamment dans les CRPE
dans la façon dont nous interviendrons
auprès des collectivités la question de
la cohérence globale ça c'est vraiment
indispensable et mais par contre on a
donc effectivement cette coopération sur
la mise en oeuvre avec Lana qui dont
j'attends moi de de des résultats
importants on sera vigilant aussi
puisqu'on avait jusqu'à présent un rôle
en soutien de la mise en place des
services d'accompagnement à la
rénovation énergétique aujourd'hui c'est
la répartition est faite et on peut se
féliciter je crois que qui est une
certaine clarté qui a été mise sur ce
sujet parce que vous le rappeliez très
juste titre l'habitat et les
consommations énergétiques dans
l'habitat c'est un sujet absolument
fondamental
merci je vais donner la parole à Daniel
Guéret
bonjour monsieur Révillon monsieur le
candidat moi je ne vous connais pas
personnellement et comme à chaque
exercice
comme celui auquel on se livre ce matin
lorsque l'on additionne un candidat à
une fonction
on recherche sur lui les éléments sur
son parcours nul doute que
vos compétences votre parcours des lieux
local et de ce point de vue extrêmement
intéressant et le seul fait que ça a été
souligné par mes collègues vous ayez été
brillabond réélu suffit pour moi à
considérer que vous avez une légitimité
qui donne à blanc saint à vos
compétences
s'agissant du sujet qui nous occupe ce
matin néanmoins je voudrais vous faire
part
d'un malaise qui est le mien
dans la discussion sur la loi 3DS nous
avons eu des débats extrêmement
intéressants et tout le monde ici
considère que l'ADEB a une mission
essentielle
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui les objectifs qui sont et
qui seront peut-être les vôtres demain
sont également essentiels dans la phase
de transition énergétique donc fonde
l'ADEME naturellement un organisme du
plus haut intérêt vous allez et vous
briguer finalement une fonction
nationale vous avez expliqué dans les
arguments qui que vous donnez de
d'employés pour répondre à mes collègues
que votre fonction des lieux locales
était sans doute et je le crois une arme
supplémentaire pour mieux exercer votre
fonction le problème c'est là où j'ai un
malaise le problème c'est que ce que
vous dites en ce qui vous concerne
aujourd'hui
c'est exactement ce que nous avons dit
pendant plusieurs années à l'opinion
lorsqu'on essayait de convaincre qu'un
parlementaire pouvait cumuler ses
fonctions avec celle d'un élu local vous
avez devant vous ici des femmes et des
hommes qui toutes et tous ont été aux
commandes de leur ville de leur village
de leur communauté pendant des dizaines
d'années nous avons tous réalisé comme
vous le faites aujourd'hui des choses
mais à la différence de vous et vous n'y
êtes pour rien c'est pas vous qui êtes
mais enfin vous êtes pour rien c'est
vous aujourd'hui ont-ils des questions
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'aborde cela
à la différence de vous nous avons d'où
nous avons dû nous faire un choix qui a
été d'abandonner nos projets et la
conduite de nos projets parce qu'on nous
a expliqué que avoir une fonction
nationale ne pouvait pas être compatible
pour des raisons de temps de
disponibilité des tiques enfin on a tout
entendu sur ce sujet pendant des années
et finalement les choses s'appliquent à
nous à nous tous et à nous toutes bon
même si je suis convaincu du contraire
c'est à dire si je suis d'accord avec
vous sur le fond or il se trouve que
vous n'êtes pas candidat ça rappelle un
poste de parlementaire vous êtes
candidats ne fonctionnelle et le fait
que vous soyez peut-être demain
président fait de vous un personnage
soit la scène nationale ce qui peut
d'ailleurs au passage expliquer les
évoluments ce qui me choque pas du reste
mais simplement je voulais m'assurer que
vous compreniez bien
le malaise qui pouvait être le nôtre
s'agissant de ce qui est vrai d'un côté
de l'état de l'autre et que j'entends ce
que vous dites je comprends ce que vous
dites je suis d'accord avec ce que vous
dites mais à la place qui est la nôtre
ce qui est vrai pour vous n'a pas été
vrai pour nous alors voilà je voulais je
voulais quand même m'assurer que vous
étiez conscient de cela
parce que c'est un véritable problème et
moi je m'interroge aussi sur finalement
la disponibilité qui sera qui sera la
vôtre quand vos territoires sur lesquels
vous exercez des fonctions pourront
prétendre un certain nombre de
politiques de l'ADEME et bien vous serez
dans une situation aussi qu'on nous a
renvoyé bien des fois je fais partie
ceci et cela voilà donc simplement il
faut que vous compreniez que il peut y
avoir sur cette question
un vrai sujet et que ça ne remet en
aucun cas le doute de vos compétences
sur votre parcours mais ce qui est vrai
d'un côté devrait l'être de l'autre même
si la loi ne l'oblige pas enfin je veux
dire que vous n'êtes pas candidat un
poste de second ordre vous êtes candidat
à un poste de responsabilité nationale
et je suis de ce point de vue là
interpellé en qualité de parlementaire
voilà Monsieur le candidat ce que je
voulais m'assurer que ça ne vous échappe
pas
merci je vais donner la parole à Madame
Préville est-ce que je vous propose
c'est qu'on arrête à 10h10 puisque après
il faudra voter et après on a
effectivement un autre sujet
merci monsieur le Président donc je suis
par là donc bien sûr comme mes collègues
je m'interroge mais à un autre niveau
sur le fait que vous mainteniez dans vos
fonctions électives de mandat
local puisque moi il me semble que
l'investissement que vous devriez avoir
en tant que président Directeur de
l'ADEME l'investissement l'implication
et notamment l'ouverture d'esprit et la
créativité qui à mon avis sont celles
qui doivent prévaloir à la direction et
à la présidence d'un tel organisme
notamment sur des choix très importants
je vous ai écouté quand vous avez relaté
les scénariés de transition énergétique
et sur pas le pas le jugement mais le
regard que vous avez porté je me demande
en fait qu'elle regarde vous pourriez
porter sur tout le reste du champ
d'application de de l'ADEME
notamment parce que en tant que mère et
président d'agglomération vous avez fait
des choix et nous avait vous nous avez
parlé par exemple de la Tom et
incitative est-ce le stade ultime de
gestion des déchets qu'elle est
l'ouverture et le la créativité et le
rôle différent que doit être l'ADEME et
l'autre regard qu'on doit porter sur les
choses qu'est-ce que voilà je
m'interroge sur ce sujet là parce qu'en
tant qu'élu local vous avez fait des
choix mais en fait la Dev en fait se
préoccupe et ouvre en fait le champ des
possibilités bien plus que cela et donc
c'est l'interrogation que je l'ai voilà
sur ce sujet là mais
merci je vous propose de répondre à mes
deux collègues merci
merci monsieur le Président alors ça te
dirai je
effectivement vous me placez devant une
situation qui qui dont je ne suis pas
totalement l'auteur puisque les textes
ça effectivement pas moi ça ne peut pas
échappé qui les ai qui les a établis
notamment sur l'interdiction du cumul ce
que je peux est-ce que je veux vraiment
vous redire c'est que je suis moi
absolument convaincu absolument
convaincu d'être tout à fait en capacité
de gérer à la fois la présidence pleine
et entière de l'ADEME avec effectivement
comme dans c'était dans le cas dans la
gouvernance jusqu'à présent une
direction générale déléguée
et donc conserver ce mode de
fonctionnement et d'être capable parce
que là encore
si tu pas au début de de mes mandats
électifs à Charleville-Mézières mais
il y a un petit peu avancée justement
dans ce temps des tout à fait capable
d'arriver à gérer cela et c'est
me semble-t-il un sujet qui qui pour moi
est fondamental je
pouvais ne pas être candidat à cette
question mais j'en ai fait moi
cette question de l'ancrage de garder un
ancrage territorial une condition
parce que je suis attaché à ce à ces
mandats et puis parce que surtout je
crois vraiment et je vais revenir sur ce
que vous dites madame Préville
sur le sur le
l'utilité que ça présente et et je le
crois aussi alors que on veut que
l'ADEME se développe les contacts avec
les élus locaux et bien de pouvoir se
parler entre guillemets entre
entre élus et personne confrontée au
même difficulté me semble-t-il devrait
faciliter grandement les choses alors il
va de soi qu'il y a un sujet de de
conflits d'intérêt potentiels à régler
et que des sujets qui concerneraient
Charleville-Mézières l'agglomération ou
même le département des Ardennes ne
pourrait
président de l'ADEME plus être connu de
moi
des dispositions existent dans ces
cas-là les textes permettent
effectivement d'organiser un déport de
l'instruction des des sujets et donc je
crois pas de difficulté il va de soi
bien sûr que
l'ADEME doit avoir un traitement
absolument équitable de tous les
territoires
impartial et donc non biaisé et donc que
si les territoires rouges conserve
effectivement des intérêts un
attachement venait à répondre à des
appels etc enfin je n'aurais je ne
devrais en aucun cas pouvoir en
connaître donc ça ça s'organise et ça ça
doit ça doit pouvoir se faire moi je
vais pas
rebondir et sur le sur le le
sujet du cumul mais je crois je crois
effectivement et c'est plus le résultat
d'une réflexion de long terme que que
couper
l'exercice de mandat nationaux et et de
fonctions locales
comporte peut-être à l'arrivée plus
d'inconvénients que que ça ne présente
davantage mais c'est pas je suis pas ici
c'est la vie là de Boris Ravignon et
c'est et le président de l'ADEME n'a pas
je crois de manière habituelle à
s'exprimer sur sur ce sujet là si ce
n'est que effectivement ça ça concerne
ça me concerne dans le dans le cadre
d'exercice de ses fonctions que que
j'envisage
alors
la satisatrice Préville effectivement je
j'ai fait des choix locaux mais et ces
choix locaux il me je croyais mon
sensibilisé ils m'ont permis de
comprendre l'importance du sujet de la
réduction des ordures ménagères la
difficulté des différentes voix et moyen
de d'y parvenir en aucun cas il ne
s'agit pour moi de d'aller appliquer ou
faire appliquer par l'ADEME ce qui
serait un modèle carolo massérien c'est
c'est on en est pas là on en est pas là
parce que d'abord je vous le dis je vous
prie de me croire je crois que chaque
territoire doit trouver sa voie pour
résoudre les problèmes qu'il s'agisse de
déchets de développement des énergies
renouvelables de sobriété énergétiques
de développement des mobilités douces
etc c'est à chacun de le faire garderai
bien porter le moindre jugement et mais
la dame elle est là pour accompagner
finalement tous les élus dans le dans
leur choix quand avec simplement une
exigence c'est que c'est que les choix
faits qui sont tous s'ils sont soutenus
par la puissance publique par des moyens
publics bien te permettre d'atteindre
les objectifs c'est-à-dire qu'on ne
fasse pas les choses à moitié qu'on soit
pas dans un finalement dans un dans un
soutien un peu factice à des démarches
qui
n'aboutiraient pas qu'il n'iraient pas
résolument vers la transition écologique
donc je non
l'ouverture de l'ADEME et au niveau de
l'instruction des contacts avec les élus
elle me semble absolument devoir être
garantie parce que c'est c'est comme ça
que nous allons pouvoir continuer à
travailler et accompagner efficacement
les élus dans les écoutant en étant à
leur écoute et en essayant de voir
comment on peut mobiliser les moyens que
nous donne la puissance publique pour
pour aller vers les objectifs de la
transition écologique
merci et je vais laisser la conclusion à
notre rapporteur Martin de Sidrac merci
président alors je ne sais pas si ce
sera une conclusion en tout cas je
souhaitais vous remercier de vous être
prêtés au jeu des questions réponses et
d'avoir répondu sur les volets
techniques de pour ma part que je
considère des réponses rassurantes
toutefois vous avez observé monsieur
Ravignon un certain nombre de questions
sur le volet gouvernant je vais
l'appeler comme ça sur le volet aussi
cumul en fait de vos fonctions des Luc
locales et de la candidature que vous
briguez aujourd'hui devant notre notre
assistance
je j'ai je suis un petit peu dubitatif
pardonnez-moi je ne doute pas de vos
compétences je ne doute pas de votre
motivation toutefois être président
directeur général d'un grand opérateur
national sur un volet éminemment
important qui est celui de la transition
écologique je me dis que bon dans une
semaine on a que 7 jours on a que 24
heures dans la journée je ne sais pas
comment vous envisagez véritablement de
consacrer le temps nécessaire pour bien
mener ses missions importantes avec un
budget qui est on augmentation ce qui
suppose donc des ambitions encore plus
fortes et ce qui suppose aussi des
missions encore plus fournies donc je
vous remercie encore une fois de vous
être prêté à cet exercice et puis ben
écoutez nous allons nous allons
président j'imagine procéder au vote et
puis nous nous aurons l'occasion sans
doute de nous reparler je vous remercie
merci merci effectivement pour pour vous
répondre
je vais vous libérer parce qu'il faut
que vous allez Assemblée nationale n'est
ce pas et puis je rappelle à mes
collègues que nous allons procéder au
vote
je vous rappelle qu'il n'y a aucune
délégation de votre possible et que le
dépouillement doit s'effectuer
simultanément entre notre commission et
celle de l'Assemblée nationale et ça
pourra se faire pense vers 13h30 je
rappelle enfin que vous devez inscrire
pour
qu'on
ou si voter blanc rien vous mettez pas
le mot rien vous me laissez en blanc
et rien d'autre sur votre bulletin parce
que si vous écrivez autre chose que pour
ou contre il sera considéré comme nul
nous allons à présent vous appeler
nominati nominalement pour venir déposer
votre bulletin dans l'urne